he shut the door stood on the toilet and
looked over the top of the cubicle and
said
what's this
as soon as he said that the door burst
open again and these four hooded figures
came in and they started walking around
me
slowly
and as they were walking around me
one of them would
punch me headbutt me as this was going
on the guy was looking down at me asking
me questions and i became convinced that
i wasn't going to leave there in one
piece
[Music]
i sort of fell into undercover work and
and sort of drugs obsessive policing
really because there was the biggest
moral panic in the united kingdom about
drugs going on
and that moral panic was about crack
cocaine because the newspapers had been
publishing these stories for
uh for years really about the crack
epidemic in the united states and what a
catastrophe it's going to be as soon as
it hits the streets of britain the
government instructed all the police
forces to prioritize above anything else
the investigation of heroin and crack
cocaine above anything domestic violence
or
any other kind of thing and so that's
how i ended up being given 20 pounds
and pointed to this
blue terraced house door in the city of
derby
and knocking on that door and asking to
to buy my first
uh deal of of drugs for the police was
it scary
my you know the first time yeah my my um
my stomach was doing some assaults you
know i i was i was certainly nervous
but um i didn't give myself chance to
get scared particularly and
to be fair
it wasn't that difficult because this
guy didn't know me i just knocked on
this door and he said to me um
who are you then
you're not a student are you innate
students
and at that moment i thought hang on i
don't know what i am i haven't made up a
cover story or anything
so i thought well that'll do i says yeah
yeah i'm a student
and this woman behind him said god is he
stupid you've just told him you hate
students but then he laughed and says
yeah but what fool would i admit to
being one now
um
and so he says yes what do you want then
and i love it i said i have a 20 pound
stone it was actually not difficult that
day not really
because
he didn't know that the police were
doing using that tactic
but of course he went to jail and then
everyone suddenly did know that the
police were doing were using new tricks
and so
in order to have a successful operation
from that point onwards it had to take a
lot more effort and constantly adapting
you're now a undercover narcotics
policeman what does a day look like
the beginning of an operation for the
first few weeks
i would be
spending time building my legend making
the connections working out who it is
that i can
use to
best introduce me further up the ladder
you know who's got those contacts it's
all about finding out
who knows who and who and who's useful
but in terms of practically what i did
for the start of the day well i realized
that it was particularly useful for me
to
dress down and actually look like i fit
in with the street community you know
the people who are homeless or living in
squats the people who are really living
on the edge of edge of society if i look
like them
i could fit in with them quicker
what happens to you in the field if
you're offered some drugs
well i mean there were occasions when i
had to use drugs undercover there were a
small amount of times when i used
cannabis but
it's just cannabis isn't it
[Music]
there was a time
when i had to use amphetamine um and
that's because this person who'd given
it to me
they i made this really stupid mistake
by basically making myself out to be a
connoisseur of amphetamines
and i'm clearly not
but this person gave me this this
amphetamine and he says wow i bet you've
never had anything like this
and i thought no how right you are
but i had this moment of reticence on my
face which i knew he picked up on i saw
this split second of suspicion at my
reticence so i thought well i'm going to
have to pull war throw water on this
fire of suspicion instantly to put it
out which meant i had to
enthusiastically dip my finger in this
bag and show
willing
and
this uh this
amphetamine in this bag this pink toxic
looking goo in this little sealy bag
uh would turn out to be incredibly
strong it was 40 pure as opposed to what
was normally five percent pure at that
time in the market
and it smelt like the the urine from a
glue sniffing cat you know that sort of
uriney
toxic
smell
and i sort of almost felt the mouthfuls
falling on my tongue as i had it
and because i didn't have any tolerance
it meant i was completely out of it i
was absolutely
destroyed
and it was not a comfortable experience
at all
i knew enough about it i wasn't going to
have an overdose but it was well beyond
a comfortable dose i wasn't very anxious
indeed and so i had to get driven home
and
i didn't actually sleep properly for
three nights didn't sleep at all for the
first two nights that's how strong it
was mind you my house has never been so
tidy i can tell you
could you talk us through your biggest
case
yeah i suppose um my biggest case is
that against the burger bar boys in
northampton this operation was sold to
me i was talked into it and they said
woodsy
we need you to do this job because this
gang are
using sexual violence
to intimidate people they're gang raping
people
you know they're doing all the normal
kind of gangster stuff kidnappings
maimings and all of that kind of thing
but they're all you know that just for
reputation building they're using sexual
violence
and there were six of them that taken
over the heroin and crack cocaine supply
in northampton
using violence to do that one of them
was implicated and i saw some of the
intelligence on this one of them was
implicated in seven different murders in
birmingham
and
he was uh apparently responsible for
sourcing the machine guns for the murder
of leticia shakespeare and charmaine
harris i think in 2004
it'll be i think and so they were a
really dangerous gang and so i thought
okay
i need to work and and
try and catch these people and you know
up until that point i was buying heroin
off people but what i would do is i
would moan and complain saying it's not
the bags aren't big enough it's not good
enough i need a hook up right to the
prop to the right to the main people you
know
and eventually managed to get that
introduction
and i'll never forget that the day i i
got that intro um
i was taken to
where they were sort of holding court
their sort of local headquarters in the
snooker club right in the center of
northampton
straight into the uh
the gents toilets and
i was stood there for a few minutes and
the guy who was going to be introducing
me was looking terrified over to my left
and then the door burst open and this
hooded figure walked in and he went into
the cubicle
he shut the door stood on the toilet and
looked over the top of the cubicle and
said
what's this
as soon as he said that the door burst
open again and these four-hundred
figures came in and they started walking
around me
slowly
and as they were walking around me
one of them would
punch me head-butt me
i think it was a head butt on the side
of the head right on my ear so it really
hurt
and then a few seconds later one would
would punch me in the ribs or push me in
the other and then that would on the
other side the other one would punch me
and as as this was going on the guy was
looking down at me asking me questions
and then asking my mate questions
and then rephrasing the same question
trying to catch me out and he was asking
how long we'd known each other and
uh and because my mate had made me learn
a cover story to say that we'd known
each other for much longer
which is really confusing when you're an
undercover cop who've got you've got a
cover story and just had to learn a new
one on top of it and i became convinced
that i wasn't going to leave there in
one piece
because it was hurting and
i knew their capacity for extreme
violence and i just thought
it was just going to explode in any
moment
anyway eventually he said to me
alright then what do you want
and i looked up at him said
i love one on one please
polite as you like and uh and i handed
him 40 pounds and he gave me a 0.4 of
heroin and a 0.4 of crack
and that was the most important moment
for the operation really because we
exchanged phone numbers
he put me in his memory
and
from that day onwards i started
gathering evidence of conspiracy against
the whole gang and i bought from all of
them
and i carried on doing for for months
and more than any other operation
certainly from that point onwards
i was
constantly in fear when i was operating
when i was out on the streets constantly
in fear of immediate violence
that it could happen at any time because
they wouldn't they'd never let up on the
the intimidation
and
just that sense of imminent
violence
the development of that kind of
undercover work and the procedures
developed really quickly
although there was no training for it
for the first four years at all if i
wanted to if if a constabulary or or
special operations team wanted to to use
an operative
then i would be loaned to them that team
would have to be completely cocooned
completely separate from normal policing
operations totally separate and in fact
by the end of the 1990s before any
operation started that team would be
briefed they would be told
you must not
ask the undercover operative their real
name
you must not
ask them where they're from and you will
be disciplined if you do now the reason
for that
is to protect my safety and the reason
that they had to do that with fellow
cops is because it didn't take too long
to realize
that corruption was a massive problem
with drugs investigations that
information leaked and obviously
information leaking when you've got an
undercover undercover operative on the
ground that's potentially
extremely dangerous potentially
fatal
so those
systems were put in place to protect my
anonymity so which it became a very
lonely place really because
i was using the same pseudonym
to the problematic drug users and the
gangsters on the street
as i was to my police colleagues no one
even knew
my real name and that was to protect
my safety which i can tell is not
particularly reassuring
if that's the best they can do for
systems to protect you
would it be fair to say that the police
accept that there is internal corruption
the fact that those systems are in place
is in itself proof that the corruption
exists
there is only a need for those
safeguards
if that corruption
is a problem
those systems
are
an acceptance
of that corruption
what were the drug addicts that you met
like
when i went into the police i had a very
stigmatized view of people who had a
problem with drugs i looked down on them
i did
i didn't i didn't read i didn't know
i just saw them as people
who had made a mistake stupid enough to
try the drugs in the first place and
didn't have the mental willpower to get
themselves out of it but when i started
working undercover i realized the people
i had to get to know were those people
who were struggling with problematic
heroin or crack cocaine news or both
and i realized actually that they were a
massive selection of people
and
i realized
that
they were where they were because of
what had happened to them or more often
than not what had been done to them
and i realized that they were vulnerable
people who were struggling who needed
help i understand i i learned that
fairly quickly and i was very keen to
keep learning about these people really
for selfish reasons though because if i
understood their motivations how how
they worked what made them tick it could
make me a better undercover officer
and i very cynically
manipulated them and i picked on the
most vulnerable people i sought out and
i looked for the most vulnerable people
because the most vulnerable are the
easiest to manipulate
and that's the game i was in
but there were many really nice people
and thoughtful people and intelligent
people who had just ended up where they
were
for circumstances out of their control i
remember in northampton it was a woman
who went by the name of uma and one day
just because to try and offset some
suspicion i was playing rattling i was
having a day where i was making out i
didn't have much money
and um since she saw me she said oh mate
mate you're hanging out aren't you
you're struggling
and i went yeah yeah and she reached
into a pocket and she handed me a fiver
and i says but hang on you're going to
need that on you
she says no it's fine
you know i'm i've just had a hit i'm
going to be all right for a good few
hours i've got time to earn some some
back but you need it now you need it
more than me
and
i've never come across such pure
generosity anywhere because she needed
that
to avoid
her pain and to feel better
but she just empathized with me or how
she perceived me to be that i was
rattling that i was in pain and so her
first response without a thought was to
give me that money it was incredible and
one day she told me uma
she said well i can stop taking heroin
anytime i want and actually every few
weeks i do i take a fortnight's break to
bring down my tolerance so it's so it's
you know easier to maintain the habit
she says but the trouble is when i stop
taking heroin
i become suicidal
because then i remember the feeling of
my uncle my uncle's fingernails as he
sexually abused me as a little girl
and
that's why she
stayed on heroin
to block out that emotional pain
[Music]
sometimes some operations
it felt like i was on the wrong side
quite frankly
was it the same for the sellers as well
most dealers of heroin and crack cocaine
are people who are being exploited
by organized crime
they are being exploited and pushed into
dealing
and they're pushed into finding new
customers
but they're pushed into it because
they've got their own habit
and of course they're exploited because
if they deal
for the organized crime gangs the actual
gangsters then they get their supply
free
and and yet these people
who are the dealers
are treated as dealers by the courts and
get extraordinary long sentences when
actually they need rescuing from that
exploitation and they need help there
was and there's one particular one
particular um
dealer if you can call him a dealer
he was a 16 year old and he was part of
this gang that i
got got into and i was buying regularly
off
when i met him he was 16 and he was
actually
one of the nicer ones i could have a
laugh with him he was good fun he was a
bit cheeky
and i saw him change from a fun-loving
16 year old
to a terrifying 17 year old over the
space of six months
and the reason he changed and changed so
rapidly is because the group that he was
with made it clear to him
how you had to behave to survive in that
world
because by policing drugs by having
undercover cops like me in that
marketplace or police informants in that
marketplace
it creates a darwinian situation where
the ones who are successful who don't
get caught who don't get grassed up
they're the ones who are prepared to be
the most ruthless
who who can who can show extreme
violence to intimidate people
can we get onto them why you decided to
quit eventually
even though i knew i was causing harm to
vulnerable people i justified that harm
because i saw it that the end justifies
the means
that because i was going to catch these
gangsters at the end of the operation
the harm i was going to cause to
individuals was justified
for every passing year
the streets got more dangerous and it
got more dangerous because of the
presence of people like me in that
marketplace
and these people become more violent and
they become and they turn it into an art
form even
because that's how you don't get caught
and the harder we police this
the more we sharpen that sword
the more we encourage that brutality by
forcing that competition on the streets
but the problem is
police never reduce the size of the
market it actually happened in the 1990s
when all of those resources were
directed into drugs policing by the home
office twice the resources twice as many
twice the prison sentences prisons
filled
up the markets never reduce the size of
the market never shrinks
so
more often than not especially in our
inner cities
successful
drugs policing
increases violence i realized i couldn't
i can't
i couldn't be in the police anymore and
this conflict
i was also starting to have a breakdown
because of my ptsd
uh profound sense of guilt for the home
that i'd caused to individuals
i had to get out
and
because i have this knowledge and this
experience
i
am
duty-bound
to try and explain it to the public
because if the public understood these
things
the public would insist of their
politicians that we change policy
and if you could just summarize what the
word is to be spread
what would that be we must end this war
on drugs we must end drug prohibition
and by that
i don't just mean the decriminalization
of people who use drugs of course we
should stop criminalizing people who use
drugs but what i mean
is i'm looking at this through a police
lens we need to take this power away
from organized crime we have to take the
drug markets away from criminals we have
to legally regulate drugs
to take the power away from organized
crime
to save lives and make a safer society
and i i'd like to actually address any
other any police out there who's
listening to this and i would encourage
you
to also turn the blind eye i would
encourage you to decide not to young to
ruin some young person's life by
arresting them and
and putting them into the criminal
justice system
for possession
of drugs because it does ruin people's
lives i would encourage you to turn a
blind eye i would encourage you to
ignore
[Music]
your orders in that regard you know as
as this movement carries on as this
movement grows internationally amongst
police
the movement who want to stop this war
on drugs
then there will be more people inclined
to stand up to
those orders there will be more people
inclined
to refuse
to criminalize young people like that
now i know that police now have
a diversion schemes many police they
don't have to arrest they don't have to
um
prosecute people they don't have to put
people into the criminal justice system
they can
divert them to health systems
but where you don't have diversion
schemes
and i would i'm encouraging descent
[Music]
i hate to strip down to next to nothing
grease out put a towel over the cut
section of bar off the window so it
wouldn't scratch my back and leave it
myself out
well stem wrenched that up just another
little inch
probably strangling everybody had always
hated since childhood but just enough
for me to get out